it's been about a month since i've
gotten my hands on the airpods max
and i don't think that i've ever been
more torn on an apple product
as i have with these 550 headphones
on one hand i want to criticize them for
costing so much
and for the inherent flaws that they
have for the price
which i will do some of in this review
but on the other hand
i really like them even though i didn't
want to
and they have some massive advantages
compared to
most headphones on the market what makes
it even worse
is that i've gone to apple's website a
few times planning to hit that return
button which is still an option thanks
to the holidays
but every time that i did i couldn't get
myself to go through with it even though
i wanted to and that's because of two
separate
very real world reasons that separate
these from the other three pairs of
headphones that i own and use
i have two more days to return them and
thankfully
i finally made up my mind so in this
review i will share both what really
surprised me using these in the last
month
as well as what has been really
frustrating and ultimately
if i'm going to be keeping them and how
i made that choice
let me start out by saying that nobody
really needs 550
headphones just like they don't need
fancy watches or clothes
you can get great noise cancelling for
half the price or better sound quality
for much less
and even exclusives like spatial audio
or siri announced messages
with in-ear airpods and that's where my
airpods max journey
started knowing that i don't really need
heavy fancy aluminum and stainless steel
headphones that are a pain to lug around
where my airpod pros can do most things
that these can
and for the few things that they lack
such as latency free video editing
i have my audio technicas and for the
now rare flights i take
the sony xm3s with that preconception i
opened up the box for the first time and
i was almost stunned
for a few reasons first the kind of ugly
simple design looked much nicer and
actually classy in person and the weight
that i read on the spec sheet
was much more real once you got them in
your hand
all of the materials felt very premium
as i had expected
and the headband was super soft and
stretchy
while not feeling thin or fragile the
first time i put them on i was surprised
by how little i felt that headband
but the clamping pressure from the ear
cups were concerning
since these really try to keep a good
seal for the active noise cancellation
and to balance the hefty weight on your
head now i rarely wear headphones for
more than two hours because they end up
being too uncomfortable to keep using
usually i get pain built up right where
the headband is
and my ears start to get quite hot so i
have to take them off at least for a
half hour
to take a break or switch to earbuds
or my studio monitors well after two
hours of straight use
i was really surprised by how little
changed from the time i put them on
the headband still felt like it wasn't
there which is crazy
and my ears felt just as cool as when i
put them on
and the clamping pressure didn't feel
any stronger
although it never really disappeared
like it does with the sonys
i continued to wear them throughout the
day only taken them off for about 10
minutes
and after over 8 hours of use i was
shocked
that they felt almost as comfortable as
when i put them on
only feeling slightly more pressure from
the headband and the ear cups
closer to that eight hour mark and i
could probably wear them for at least 12
if not more hours without an issue this
was shocking to me since i don't think
i've ever been able to wear headphones
for more than say three
hours so if you're somebody that hasn't
been able to either
and you want to apple killed the comfort
on these things
despite them weighing so much now let's
talk about an issue that has been making
some headlines and that's condensation
dylan philemon shared a massive amount
of condensation he was seeing in his
airpods max
after extended use which was quite scary
dylan later posted that he was wearing
them for 12 hours straight
which once again says something about
comfort and in a cold room
and with that i'm guessing that he has
really warm ears as well i tested this
myself in multiple environments and i
literally never had an issue after
extended use
and even when i was doing some walking
outside which causes the metal ear cups
to get cold
while it's hot or at least warm on the
inside now other people have posted that
they've seen a little bit
but nothing close to that but this
definitely could be an issue
maybe that's why apple made it so easy
to remove the ear cups
and who knows maybe other headphones can
also build up condensation too
we just can't see it with their sealed
ear cups and usually a nice covering
over the drivers
i personally would suggest that anybody
who is spending this much money on
headphones
to go ahead and add on apple care which
is reasonably priced
not only to protect from this kind of
issue but also to protect from
other things that could go wrong such as
battery longevity speaking of battery
both the battery life and charging has
been better than i expected
if you haven't heard the airpods max do
go into low power mode
after them just laying there for five
minutes compared to
instantly if you put them in their case
which is actually pretty good
but as far as their deep sleep mode it
takes about 72 hours
outside of the case instead of 18 hours
i've been mostly using the max without
the case and they seem to only lose
about five percent of their battery
just sitting there for about a day which
isn't bad at all
and when they do go into the deep sleep
mode it's more like two percent a day
as far as battery life while in use i
did multiple controlled tests and i was
surprised to find that they drained
about four percent an
hour when listening to music at 90
volume
and it didn't make a difference if it
was set to active noise cancellation
transparency mode or even just in the
off mode this might be because the dual
10 core processors are constantly
working and monitoring
and then processing the audio to make
sure that there's no distortion
and that sounds its best for your ears
and fit
and that is likely why apple didn't give
a battery life rating
without noise cancellation during my
full day test the airpods max were at 67
battery life after over eight hours of
use
which lines right up to about four
percent an hour giving us a rough
estimate of about 24 hours of battery
life
beating out apple's 20 hour claims but i
didn't stop there
i closely monitored the battery life as
it reached one percent and set a timer
to see how long they would last
since iphones seem to last quite a while
at one percent
to give you enough time to find a
charger the airpods max
ended up lasting over an hour at one
percent
charge before shutting off whereas
typically one percent would give you
15 minutes of listening and the weird
thing was that the next morning i put
them back
on and they turned on and gave me
another 15 minutes of listening
before they once again died meaning we
should have about 25 hours of real world
battery life
whereas the sony xm4s that are rated for
30 hours with active noise cancellation
in lab testing lasted just under 20
hours
once they were fully drained i wanted to
do some detailed charging tests
but first i plugged in the 35 lightning
to three and a half millimeter connector
to see if they would work when drained
and nope they didn't
it's a good thing that they charge
quickly with apple quoting one and a
half hours of playback in just
five minutes of charge and i believe it
because after five minutes
of me plugging them in they were at two
percent battery
matching up perfectly with how fast they
drained after 10 minutes the headphones
were at 10
and then after 30 minutes at 44
so a half hour charge will get you over
10 hours of use
at the one hour mark the headphones were
at 70 percent
and to get to 90 it takes about an hour
and 35 minutes
now what's interesting is that once they
hit 90 charge
they stop charging and just sit there
for a long while
even though there is no optimized
charging toggle so it definitely seems
like apple is trying to maintain
battery longevity what's even more
interesting is how little power
they use when charging i tested them
when they were at one percent and they
only pulled 2.4 watts
from either an old 5 watt brick an old
cable or the new 20 watt usbc power
adapter and the included usb c
cable so if you charge them from your
laptop or power bank
barely any power is needed that 2.4 watt
draw
is maintained until they reach 50
percent at just over a half
hour and then it drops to 1.8 watts
until
70 charge from 70 to 80 the airpods max
only draws 0.8 watts
and from 80 to 85 it's 0.4
and then from 85 to 90 they trickle
charge
going from zero watts to 0.2 and back
and forth
so apple is being very conservative
even more so than when charging iphones
to make sure the battery lasts a long
time now as far as usability
i only have one complaint but first
let's talk about the good
i absolutely love the controls not only
do they feel
nicer and more tactile than any i've
ever used in the past
but they work so well the digital crown
is
awesome for adjusting volume for pausing
and changing tracks
and the headband is very easy to adjust
and it stays exactly how you set it i
also like that the lightning port is on
the right hand side
since my speaker headphone output is on
the right side as well
as are all of the current macbooks the
smart case is still dumb
and ugly but it has been fined the times
that i've used it
and yes it doesn't protect the
headphones very well but over the last
month of use they still look like
they're brand new
without any marks or scratches where the
cans hit each other
the only thing that i wish is for the
cans to fold in like many others do
so i could pack them down smaller for
travel which hopefully the rumored sport
versions will have
before i get into sound quality i want
to quickly touch on active noise
cancellation
and transparency it's incredible
the transparency mode is so far better
than anything else
out there it's so good that i've
literally forgotten that i've had these
headphones on while having a
conversation
just to realize it after it is 99
true to live absolutely awesome the
active noise cancellation is
also top notch beating out the bose 700s
and the sony xm4s that i tested side by
side
i've worn them in a variety of loud
situations and they do a shockingly good
job at canceling out both low
and high frequency sounds when i first
got them i wore them as i was getting
into my truck
and i started it and then a few seconds
later i tried to start my truck again
because i literally didn't hear the
rumble from the v8 engine
at all which was crazy so if you want
good active noise cancellation you
definitely
won't be disappointed and now let's talk
about sound
quality i have to say that i am not a
crazy audiophile but i have opted to pay
thousands more to upgrade my sound
systems and my vehicles
and i have had some really nice surround
sound systems that cost
more than the rest of my media system
combined
so i definitely appreciate good sound
the airpods max
sound fantastic and absolutely smoke
their less expensive
noise canceling competition now do they
sound as good as 500
wired headphones that need dedicated
multi-hundred dollar amplifiers and lack
any sort of smart features well actually
they might and let me explain these
headphones are very well balanced and
apple wants to keep it that way without
giving you any way to control it
with an eq control like many of the
competitors do
now many audiophiles want brighter and
more detailed highs
which i can't understand and i went
ahead and went into the headphone
accommodations and adjusted them to do
so
like quinn showed in his review and i
did like it for many songs
but with other tracks the high
frequencies were just too sharp
so i had to keep going back and forth
and toggling this setting
personally i'm somebody that loves bass
and i found it a bit
lacking in many songs compared to other
headphones
although the bass is very tight and
accurate compared to the boomy xm4s
so i adjusted the equalizer in the
spotify app which helped out in some
songs
but it ended up being a bit too much in
others after about a week i turned
everything off and set it back to normal
and i've been enjoying them this way
ever since and i've come to realize that
even though these
are somewhat colored overall they are
much more balanced than other mainstream
headphones
and the songs where bass is lacking
that's how the artist intended it
unlike the sony's which give bass to
pretty much all
songs and the songs where the highs seem
subdued
are actually supposed to be like that
instead of being
sharp all around one area that has
absolutely shocked me
is sub bass and soundstage i have 19
speakers which includes a few subs in my
truck
and it sounds super good but i'm hearing
and feeling bass in songs
with the airpods max that i've never
heard before let me tell you that it is
really weird to
feel the headphones vibrate my head and
my ears instead of just hearing bass
and this is something that no other
headphones i've used can touch
and high-end open-back headphones that
have insane clarity
can't offer this at least as far as i
know or
heard which is why i mentioned that
these might actually sound better for
some
users if you want to have good bass good
highs and especially that sub bass
this also translates to watching movies
using spatial audio
the surround sound works fairly well and
the effect is cool
but having that sub bass that is usable
down to 25 hertz
can match or even beat out many surround
sound systems
and that is amazing that combined with
the excellent sound stage that matches
many open back headphones
in their price range without having that
sound leakage
is awesome and that smokes the cheaper
competitors
and then adding in the fantastic
instrument separation
leads to such a great audio experience
you take the really good audio
experience and then you add in
all the conveniences of bluetooth
headphones and the ios ecosystem goodies
like hey siri auto text readings and
replyings
icloud pairing and near instant
switching depending on which device
you're using when you put them on
and you have a real winner for those
that want active noise cancellation
having the conveniences and can't afford
the price when i first heard that these
are going to be 550
i thought apple was just being apple and
going for a cash grab
but after about a month with these i can
see why they've priced
these this high and if you value what
apple is offering
the price is justifiable but still even
though i believe that these are
worth the price tag that is still larger
than what i would want to pay for
headphones
and even though they are fantastic i
can't use them all the time like i can
with my earpod pros
which are also very good and cost less
than half the price
so i was tempted to return them but i
can't get myself to do so
because in the times that i can use them
they work so well and they sound
so good that it is worth keeping these
my only wish is that i could use them
while i'm working out which i can't
because they are way too heavy and move
around too much
and i wish that they could fold up so i
could take them with me more often
and then of course if the price tag was
a bit lower that would be great even if
that meant having to use plastic instead
of aluminum and stainless steel
i think the airpods sport could offer
all of that
and if they could maintain the noise
cancellation and the sound quality
or at least be very close those are
going to be an
absolute steal at the rumored 350
price tag go ahead let me know your
thoughts on the airpods max i will have
a link
down in the video description to them if
you want to pick them up click that
circle above if you guys want to
subscribe and see
more videos and if you want to see some
comparisons with the sony's
or the bose very detailed ones we have
them right over there thank you guys for
watching has been max and i'll catch you
in the next video
you